[Music]
hey you playstation gamer
do you like free games how about 10 of
them
following on from ratchet and clank
earlier this month which is still
available until the last day of march by
the way
sony have outlined 10 more free games
you can download over spring 2021
all thanks to their play at home
initiative these games come without
any strings no need to have ps plus no
subscriptions needed at all
as long as you have a ps4 or ps5 they
are free
for life the following games will be
available from march 25th
and stick around because the final game
is horizon zero dawn
the complete edition but we have to wait
until april for that
one the first nine games are smaller
more indie focused games
ranging from puzzlers to rhythm games
and a load of psvr compatible games too
abzu kicks things off from the creators
of journey
abzu takes us on an underwater
exploration
there are no weapons there are no
typical fights and not a word is spoken
abzu just exists to be a meditation
video game
swimming with schools of fish and
dolphins finding ancient ruins becomes
the reason to finish the game and
swimming which most of us haven't had
access to for a year plus now
is a joy next we have enter the gungeon
a roguelike dungeon crawler which is
totally focused on shooting enemies with
a multitude of weapons
the enemies are plentiful and dodging
bullets becomes a key ability
we even have a dodge roll for impossible
situations
the weapons can range from typical
rifles and snipers
to out of this world weapons like a
ninja sword that can slow down time
and a spinning flamethrower the gungeon
has a random generation element
making each playthrough different and
there's also a multiplayer option for
the die hard shooter fans
game 3 is res infinite in a cyberspace
zone attacked by digital bugs we guide
our character through the chaos
to find awaken and defeat a final boss
corrupting the world res is an on-rail
shooter completely dedicated to the
music
you create with every shot you take res
infinite can be played on ps4 and psvr
and i have to say vr makes this game
feel the greatest
just remember the tunes you create will
be stuck in your head for days
afterwards
next back to the underwater we go with
subnautica
i haven't played this one the blurb says
we crash land on an alien ocean planet
forcing us to explore under the waves
from there it's a case of survival
managing health hunger thirst and oxygen
levels
other modes remove some of the survival
elements and the hardcore mode
introduces permadeath yep only one life
truly terrifying figuring out which
creature is friend rfo
looks very interesting to me so i'm
gonna try it game five is the witness
if you're a puzzle game fan and you
haven't played the witness you are
missing out
after awaking on the beach of a new
island you'll discover everything here
is a puzzle
brain teasers or something to perplex
you surprisingly there's an interesting
story which evolves in ways i didn't
expect
with this one i say don't be fooled by
the basic art style the witness
received a boatload of nines and perfect
10 out of 10 scores
now let's move on to psvr games if you
have a ps5
you'll know how absolutely perfect
astros playroom is
well that isn't the first game in the
series japan studios made an astro game
on
vr and it's brilliant astro bot rescue
mission
i was skeptical of trying a vr based
platformer but i shouldn't have been
we are physically in the world and must
move our body to avoid attacks from
enemies all while directing astro over
bottomless pits and other obstacles
seeing things in 3d and moving your head
to judge gaps
is difficult to explain so i'll say this
if you have psvr and haven't played
astro bot rescue mission
you really should and hey it's free
game seven is moss and just like astro
this is another vr platform puzzler you
shouldn't miss
this time we are in charge of guiding a
rodent through the world
in about a three to four hour journey
quill will use sign language to talk to
you
as we free this tiny kingdom from a
fire-breathing snake and rescue his
uncle
all in a day's work next up is thumper a
horror game in the form of a rhythm game
mechanically thumper is a basic vr game
all about timing button presses on a
roller coaster
on the way to hell to be clear thumper
can be played outside of vr but like rez
earlier vr brings this genre into a
perfect space
matching the music perfectly makes the
game captivating but i do have to admit
the horror themed score left me in an
aggressive mood after playing
especially when i failed a boss fight
game nine is paper beast
the final psvr game on the list which
takes us to a world of sentient beings
made of origami without a doubt this is
an
art piece rather than a game and lacks
direction often
i'll admit it it's confusing the puzzles
here are usually easy to solve
although sometimes they are so easy
you'll be unable to figure them out
the game evolves and allows us to change
the terrain and take control of the
paper beast world
so those are the nine games which are
available from march 25th to april 23rd
but wait there's one more and it's huge
on april 19th we can download and keep
forever
totally free horizon zero dawn
and it's the complete addition to all of
eloy's travels in one game download
eloy is a hunter in a world of
technology fending off
robot dinosaurs without a doubt this is
a playstation master class
live through aloy's childhood and
upbringing and become the leader you are
always meant to be
unlocking the history of the world and
what the heck happened to civilization
please don't miss out on horizon zero
dawn i'll be sure to remind you in one
month from today
when horizon zero dawn drops totally
free on april 19th
so there we have it there's all 10 games
what do you think actually there's 11 if
you remembered to add ratchet and clank
to your library this month too
not bad eh i'm adam from playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure
i'll see you next time